good afternoon everyone those of you
don't know my name is agent max Lombardi
senior agent max Lombardi the reasons I
can't go into right now researcher Mel
is still out of action so I'm gonna be
taking this little uh I don't know what
was it called classroom obsession
so skip we're gonna be looking at today
is an old favorite scp-682
object class Kenner special containment
procedures and CP 682 must be destroyed
as soon as possible at this time no
means available to SCP teams are capable
of destroying scp-682 only able to cause
massive physical damage scp-682 should
be contained within a 5 meter by 5 meter
by 5 meter chamber with a 25 centimeter
reinforced acid resistance steel plate
lining all inside surfaces the
containment chambers should be filled
with hydrochloric acid until scp-682 was
submerged and incapacitated and the
attempts of scp-682 to move speak or
containment breach to be reacted to
quickly and with full force as called
for by the circumstances
personnel are forbidden to speak to
scp-682 fear of provoking a rage
state all unauthorized personnel
attempting to communicate with scp-682
will be restrained and removed by force
due to its frequent attempts at
containment bridge difficulty of
containment and capacitation and high
threat of foundation exposure scp-682 is
to be contained in cycling the
foundation will use the best of its
resources to maintain all land within 50
kilometers clear of human development
Edison okay let's move on description at
CP 682 is large vaguely reptile creature
of unknown origin it appears to be
extremely intelligent and was observed
to engage in complex communication with
SCP 79 during their limited time of
exposure in CP 682 appears to have
hatred of all life dozen which has been
expressed in several interviews during
containment see addendum 682 B we're
gonna take a listen to that in a moment
so sit tight this EP 682 has always been
observed to have extremely high strength
speed reflexes though exact levels vary
with its form 682 physical body grows
and changes very quickly growing or
decreasing in size as it consumes or
sheds material it CP 682 gains energy
from anything it ingests
organic or inorganic digestion seems to
be hated by a set of filtering gills
inside of scp-682 nostrils which are
able to remove usable matter from any
liquid solution enabling it to
constantly regenerate from the acid it's
contained scp-682 is regenerative
capabilities and resilience a staggering
and scp-682 has been seen moving and
speak with its body 87
destroyed or rotted in case of
containment bridge and CP 682 is to be
tracked and recaptured by all available
mobile task forces and no teams with
fewer than seven members are cleared to
engage
did they attempt the breaches have
numbered at 17 while successful breaches
of numbered at six
all right let me get this little
doohickey here there we go okay this is
addendum 682 B portion off record
transcript of and play why did you kill
those
if you don't talk now we will remove you
from this attempt yeah
pretty [ __ ] up okay so this is
addendum 682 D breeches with 682 listen
I'm gonna level with you you can see
this right now pretty much all of it is
protected it's just a big bundle of
redacted I'll give you the shortened
version all right one two three four
five and six handled by agent redacted
personnel insert number here kill it's
all you need to know all you need to
know miss anybody here knew somebody
called D 211
anyway I didn't think so
all right let's move on addendum 682 - e
termination options log of events 682 e
18 doctor attempts to use scp-409 on a
CP 682 general general and doctor flip
surfing 0 400 hours exposure scp-682
began to tear the point of content
causing massive trauma to they m missing
these 682 requests several times to know
what has been exposed to await hundred
hours crystallization begins spreading
much slower than normal
1200 hours scp-682 shows signs of
extreme pain and begins having seizures
[Music]
1300 hours
crystallization stops at 62 percent
conversion crystallized area explodes
causing massive physical trauma
the scp-682 1400 hours scp-682 recovers
from exposure
despite the loss of all limbs and organs
scp-682 begins regeneration stating that
it will attempt to kill and consume all
staff involved in event 682 - dat
scp-682 appears to now be immune to
scp-409 the use of other SCP items to
terminate scp-682 must now be first
tested on samples of 682 before
full-scale testing it's just common
sense people in accordance
since recommendations see document 27b -
six doctor and doctor have requested
permission to attempt the termination of
scp-682 using scp-689 the request is
currently pending approval from it's
also being suggested by dr. gears to use
SCP 182 and an attempt to communicate
with scp-682 and CB 182 was expressed
reluctance and refuses to enter the
containment chamber of scp-682 if at all
possible 180 tubes got a real good head
on the shoulders
trust me you ask me stick it in a
spaceship jettison it into space make
sure it doesn't hit the Sun yeah that
makes sure it doesn't hit the Sun
alright well folks it's been a pleasure
me and my buddy Barnes got to give him a
poker going who's gay come on come on
this guy this guy right here okay I'm
going okay you want to call me
[Music]
you